für ein arachnophobie k wäre dieser
beitrag wird jetzt schon vorbei menschen
mit angst vor spinnen ertragen oft nicht
einmal den anblick der achtbeiner auf
bildern einem echten tier gegenüber zu
stehen wäre für viele von ihnen
undenkbar
im londoner zoo können sie lernt ihre
angst zu überwinden
seit 25 jahren führen experten mit dem
friendly spyder programm spinnenphobie
schrittweise an das objekt ihrer panik
heran
zum jubiläum haben sich auch promis zu
dem kurs angemeldet zum beispiel die
popsängerin zenit 50 jahre habe ich
schon dieses trauma ich habe leute aus
dem bett geklingelt damit sie spinnen
aus meinem haus entfernt
sogar mein zweijähriger sohn musste sie
aufsammeln und raus in den garten
bringen
manchmal bin ich ins hotel gezogen weil
ich vorher einem schlafzimmer hatte und
jetzt kann ich hier durchgehend ich bin
durch das ganze haus gelaufen und alles
ich kann es kaum fassen
kursleiter dave clarke sagt die angst
müsse man ernst nehmen leute machen
manchmal witze darüber aber wenn jemand
einen autounfall verursacht bloß weil im
wagen einer spinne ist kann es ganz
schön ernst werden die menschen können
sich und andere verletzten leute mit
spinnenphobie sind wie gelähmt es ist
wichtig dass sie ihre angst überwinden
aber warum haben menschen eigentlich
solche panik vor spinnen
wir wissen ist nicht sagt der
hypnosetherapeut und klappert es ist
schreibt denn sie sind nicht gefährlich
vor allem nicht den großbritannien und
wir haben hierzulande eine enorm hohe
zahl von spinnenphobie kann
vielleicht liegt es daran dass wir uns
von der natur entfremdet haben
und selten bringt die natur so
offensichtlich in unseren persönlichen
lebensraum ein wie in form einer spinne
vielleicht liegt es also daran aber zum
teil ist es auch kulturell bedingt und
einfach anerzogen klipp und klar
erklären in dem kurs das verhalten der
spinnen 98 prozent der teilnehmer seien
anschließend in der lage eine spinne zu
berühren schätzt liefert bei der
bestsellerautoren ken follett hat es
funktioniert vielleicht hat die
vogelspinne kerl aber auch einfach nur
umwerfenden charme
vor einer stunde hätte allein der
gedanke dass ihr zutun mich ein horror
krämpfe gestürzt und jetzt spüre ich in
einer art verbundenheit mit ihr haupt
carroll die gefühle erwidert bleibt
geheimnisumwoben